was a question from no goat
6887
um
and
this question was very long and then at
the end he added an edit edit i could
have made this whole post shorter and
just asked what's the most i can get
done in the least amount of time
and this was in the context of
resistance training so basically asking
um
you know if you don't want to
necessarily train for optimal to get as
strong as possible or build as much
muscle as as quickly as you can um
you know what can you get away with to
still get a lot of the benefits while uh
trying to maximize efficiency so you
know most
most results with the the least uh
time and effort investment possible
um
and so
this
i it wasn't clear whether this was
specifically about strength or a
combination of strength and hypertrophy
for strength there was a
recent study by
one of the stronger by science coaches
pack on the minimal effective dose of
training for strength development um
if you just plug that exact phrase into
google i'm sure his paper will come up
uh and he previously authored a
brief meta-analysis on that as well so
you you can check out those two things
for a combination of strength and
hypertrophy um
i i think what i'm about to say will
will get the job done pretty well to get
you
i don't know maybe 70 percent of the
gains you would be capable of achieving
in minimal time so
first off i think you should be trading
training with pretty moderate loads and
in moderate rep ranges so i'm gonna
operationally define that as sets of
five to 15 reps you should mostly be
doing compound lifts because you're
going to be training more musculature
per
unit of time invested in per set you're
doing
frequency can be fairly low
one to two times per muscle group per
week
you don't have to do a ton of sets about
two to three sets per exercise you know
if you wanted to maximize hypertrophy
long term volume would probably need to
creep up but to get reasonably large you
don't need insane levels of training
volume um but you should have a pretty
high level of effort per set so training
uh to failure or within a rep or two of
failure so i think the most stripped
down version of this um
is so
actually this is exactly what i tell
people to do when they come to me with
this question uh they say like hey look
i don't want to spend much time training
at all maybe like an hour total per week
what should i do so
you're going to train twice a week one
day you're going to do squat overhead
press and either rows or pull-ups
whichever one you want to do
and the other day you're going to do
deadlift bench press and either rows or
pull-ups whichever one you didn't do the
first day
for the squat bench press deadlift
overhead press you're gonna do three
sets you're gonna take them all
basically to failure or until you feel
like your form is about to just
completely go to [ __ ]
um and you're gonna start with a load
that you can do for
about 15 reps and if you're gonna air
air a little bit low if you do
you know 16 18 reps the first week
that's totally fine
uh and then
week over week you just go up by five or
ten pounds and just try to maintain as
many reps as possible as the weights go
up
uh and then eventually when you hit a
five rep max and you know like oh when i
go up and wait next week i'm gonna do
fewer than five reps
you just start over so you go back to
whatever weight you did the first time
so you know you use an app use a
spreadsheet keep a training log like
make note of your weights and
performances over time
so just start over and just try to beat
the number of reps you did all the way
back up so the the weight you started
with that you could initially do for 15
reps if now you can do it for 18 cool
that's progress and that's also more
than 15 reps so the next time you start
back over just just skip that first week
and start with something that
corresponds to about 15 reps and same
same thing repeat the process build back
up and try to hit a heavier five rep max
in your kind of final week of this build
up than you did previously if you do
that cool you made progress you're
stronger and just start over again
so that's what you're going to do with
squat bench deadlift overhead press
two to three sets really go all out
every time and then for uh for rows and
pull ups pull pull-downs just you know
any any upper back training um
i i mean i think just do like three or
four sets and and just hammer them um
no one's gonna ask what your one rep max
row is uh
so you know you're just you're just
trying to crank it out get the work get
the work in uh and i don't think you
need to think about those too terribly
hard if you can maintain
more than 15 reps over three or four
sets add some more weight to the bar uh
if you guessed too heavy and by the last
set you're you're not able to complete
five or six reps take a little weight
off the bar but
you know just just really get after it
for three or four sets and you'll be
good so
um
six six total exercises two training
sessions per week
um
you know that's not gonna that's not
gonna make you the most muscular or the
strongest person in the world but
you should be able to get all of that
done in about 30 minutes per session and
uh you know
most people should be able to make
pretty decent gains from that so that
that is
exactly what i would recommend
in the situation that you're describing